bonsoir les sérieux bonsoir nous sommes
toujours en compagnie de marie lise le
plus
michel serbe
bruno solo
et nous accueillons neutralité du samedi
20 heures ce soir marielle blanche et
bonsoir
alors marielle vous avez mis au monde et
vous élevez 12 enfants et vous raconter
cette vie hors du commun dans un livre
intitulé ils eurent beaucoup d'enfants
publié aux éditions des arènes et vous
nous raconterez votre histoire à 20
heures
[Musique]
bonsoir
vous êtes né le 16 octobre
1968 à bordeaux d'une famille
hollandaise
installé dans le médoc votre père était
dans le commerce de cuir et votre mère
femme au foyer où elle s'occupait de ses
trois enfants alors bizarrement enfants
vous n'êtes pas du genre à jouer avec
les poupées oui c'est ça j'ai deux
frères et donc on habitait dans le médoc
dans les bois et donc ont joué au foot
on faisait des cabanes et c'est là que
je me suis épanoui enfants après une
scolarité assez ennuyeuse et un bac
scientifique
vous intégrez la fac des sciences de
bordeaux est en troisième année vous
partez à londres dans le cadre du
programme erasmus et c'est là que vous
allez rencontrer pierre lui fait sa
dernière année d'école d'ingénieur et
vous êtes dans la même résidence
universitaire et on se côtoie tous les
matins sans vraiment se voir et même ça
commence un petit peu comme un teenage
movie votre histoire un jour vous
l'entendez dire ma femme plantera des
fleurs dans le jardin vous êtes très
choquée je vous êtes indépendante quand
même pierre 10,1 en plaisantant et moi
je lui réponds alors je serai pas sa
femme mais voilà mais finalement pierre
gagnera votre coeur au bal au met ball
du king's college
pierre me demande si je vais
l'accompagner au met ball et je réfléchi
pendant les vacances de pâques et je lui
donne une réponse positive et voilà tout
a commencé comme ça vous marier le 6
avril 1991 à bordeaux vous vous avez 22
ans et deux ans plus tard vous êtes une
jeune femme moderne qui courent les
rendez vous professionnels en europe oui
en fait je commence ma carrière
professionnelle dans un laboratoire
pharmaceutique
et c'est vrai que là j'ai désiré on a
désiré avoir fondé une famille avoir un
enfant ouais
quelques mois plus tard en découvrant
votre premier test de grossesse positif
vous ressentez une vraie joie quoi vous
dit l'une des plus grandes joies de ma
vie oui sulfurique malheureusement c'est
une fausse couche oui il l'a vous n'avez
plus qu'une idée en tête qui vire à
l'obsession retombées ensemble ouais
absolument après après cette fausse
couche on se demande est ce qu'un jour
je serai maire
effectivement là on se dit il faut que
tu tombes enceinte de quelques mois plus
tard vous aurez des jumeaux ça se passe
moyennement et on dois m'arrêter et donc
je suis arrêté quasiment à deux mois de
grossesse jusqu'à la fin c'est le
bonheur les jumeaux c'est à la fois le
bonheur est à la fois je dois m'arrêter
donc pour une femme active que je suis
c'est pas évident alors là avec votre
mari que je vive en hongrie parce qu'il
est muté là bas deux ans plus tard c'est
le troisième enfant puis ce sont les usa
quatrième enfant ensuite l'allemagne 5e
enfant enfin vous vous posez aso oui
dans une grande maison et c'est là que
vous passerez de cinq enfants à 12 et
d'ailleurs quand on s'est installé à
soupe ans est choquant c'est qu'on
repartirait finalement on s'est installé
là ça fait quand même neuf années de
grossesse en 20 ans oui c'est ça enfin
un enfant tous les 650 jours quand même
un oui c'est très très étonnant comme
les écarts d'âge sont toujours à peu
près les mêmes ouais surtout au début
vous connaissez les prénoms du plus
vieux aux plus jeunes oui moi j'y arrive
pas
les jumeaux s'appelle victor épaules ils
ont vingt ans enfin bientôt 20 ans
edouard à bientôt 18 ans ensuite vient
clémentine 16 ans
ensuite après clémentine c'est henri 14
ans ensuite nous avons wiki à 12 ans
théophane qui a 10 ans félix huit ans
pierre eloi sept ans
après pierre eloi ses espérances ference
voilà espérance qui a trois ans et
ensuite auguste en écharpe bravo
et beaucoup
ça
espérance c'est parce qu'avant il ya un
problème non alors là on a prévu
d'appeler l'espérance et rançonne vous
procure du plaisir parce qu'on porte la
vie ouais et en même temps c'est aussi
toute cette angoisse quoi est ce que est
ce qu'il va d'être voilà est-ce qu'il va
d'être en bonne santé est ce qu'on va
être capable physiquement psychiquement
de l'accueillir est-ce que la mayonnaise
familiale va reprendre ouais et si
toutes ces questions qu'on se pose vous
pensez pas quand même que vous aimez
ressentir l'effet des hormones de
grossesse ça je sais pas dire mariale en
étant si souvent mères est ce que vous
ne craignez pas de devenir moins femme
alors c'est quelque chose pour lequel il
faut être extrêmement vigilant
effectivement il faut faire attention
donc au reste de la famille mais aussi à
son son époux donc rester épouse et en
même temps on est aussi femmes fin je
vous rassure vous êtes
merci vraiment à votre pire accouchement
c'est celui de félix ah oui le septième
art là vous accouchez tout seul c'était
drôle oui l'anesthésiste donc ne sert à
rien évidemment et il vous en grès
presque voulaient plus venir pour rien
non oui en fait à ce moment-là je suis
donc à la clinique j'attends et au bout
d'un moment je dis est la sage femme là
je vais pousser parce que le bébé va
naître et elle me dit non non vous
poussez pas du tout sinon vous allez
tout déchirer vous allez finir en
césarienne et j si je dois finir si je
dois pas pousser finir en césairienne
appelé l'année saisi ça va pas être
possible il elle va chercher
l'anesthésiste et pendant ce temps là
bas le bébé n'est naturellement
imposition et les bébés nés les saisies
s'était fâché et me dit vous faites de
venir là pour rien enfin aulas excusez
ma job
d'été alors quelle que soit la grossesse
en fait c'est difficile mais la
récompense c'est le café au lait le
lendemain matin oui souvent j'accouche
la nuit ça se passe souvent la nuit
effectivement à la fin de ma grossesse
je me dis ah vivement le café au lait du
lendemain matin c'est la récompense
alors non la question c'est comment
fait-on pour élever correctement 12
enfants c'est une organisation quasi
militaire j'imagine que c'est le
planning de la journée est hyper au
point en même temps les douze enfants
sont parés arrivé d'un coup donc on
s'est organisé en fonction à chaque fois
alors vous avez renoncé à la femme de
ménage ce que vous dites elle serait
surmené donc c'est vrai qu'il ya
énormément de choses à la faire à la
maison et soit ce serait une femme de
ménage vraiment tous les jours qu'il
rentrerait vraiment dans le rythme est
bon c'est vrai qu'il ya vraiment du
boulot soit les enfants se prennent en
main et c'est ce qui c'est ce qu'ils
avaient bien dressés ils font pas mal de
trucs moment j'essaie g5 c'est bien
bravo
alors financièrement vous avez le
salaire d'ingénieurs de pierre et puis
2000 euros d'allocations familiales mais
aujourd'hui après les enfants car les
deux aînés auront vingt ans donc mais
oui j'arrive est
mort on gère on gère au jour le jour on
j'ai resserré mais oui oui la tendance
est très lourde tous les dix jours vous
commander 100 litres de lait
trente cinq baguettes 5 kg dessus 5 kg
de farine trente six yaourts elle 60 e +
200 kg de pommes de terre par an à ces
normes alors évidemment les moments
importants c'est noël parce que quand il
va y avoir tous les cadeaux sous l'arbre
ça doit faire mal quand même non oui
c'est un peu c'est un peu impressionnant
et parfois ça peut paraître un peu
insolent quand même moi c'est cadeau et
vous devez crouler à la fête des mères
sous les cadeaux de fête des mères vous
avez une technique est génial chaque des
cadeaux vous les éloigner du centre de
la maison ici personne ne les réclame
depuis dix ans par les mettre à la
poubelle et je les expose bien dans
l'évidence que tout le monde puisse les
admirer qu'on puisse les féliciter et
puis quand le quand c'est un peu passé
que vous pas les attacher les a
accrochées au mur et qu'on sait pas quoi
en faire les meilleurs un peu sur le
dans le coin et puis au bout d'un moment
quand je vois que c'est passé je serai
je les fait disparaître ils vont le
découvrir dans le livre ce que vous êtes
en train de dire ah
si si oui c'est possible les gens vous
regardent comment dans la rue quand vous
passez avec tous vos petits canards oies
souvent les gens s'amusent donc il se
retourne et commence à compter ils
regardent et puis en général ils ont
jamais le bon compte et y en a toujours
un derrière qui dit non en fait on est
12 ha ouais
vous voulez d'autres enfants on a
beaucoup de choses en cours à la maison
mais à la rentrée il faudra réfléchir à
tout ça j dire il faut aussi dire que il
y à peine 50 ans les famille de douze
enfants n'étaient pas rares en france
pas du tout près de 12 du côté de maman
ou gt stress donc branchez vous mais
chez mon père 11 c'est
énorme et c'est venu du fait que la
mortalité infantile s'est arrêtée de
suite auparavant une femme avait douze
enfants pour en garder trois ou quatre
et elle risquait sa vie à chaque
accouchement et donc nous sommes en
présence d'un miracle c'est ce que je
voudrais dire voilà
est ce que
est ce que ces enfants
est ce le temps quand même de vous
intéresser à la marche du monde 1 ce qui
se produit sur le plan culturel à tous
les jours je lis le journal awene entre
guillemets j'ai l'impression de vivre
une vie normale quand même ouais marie
dit c'est génial non ouais mais j'ai eu
trois enfants et je me dis mince et une
loupé quelque chose peut-être même avant
que je trouve formidable c'est d'abord
une forme de sérénité le sourire et
voilà ça a l'air tellement que ça va
être une corvée pour marielle s'avère
simple il voudrait ajouter quelque chose
que peut être les gens ne savent pas
dans le ventre d'une femme enceinte
il y à un million de réactions chimiques
à la seconde oh là là pour pouvoir aller
faire neuf mois construire des centaines
de milliards de cellules c'est à dire
chaque femme enceinte est le siège d'un
véritable miracle statistiques et c'est
ça a été le plus extraordinaire dans la
vie de s'imaginer
l'explosion des noms que ça suppose et
par conséquent il n'y a rien de plus
admirable que nous femmes enceintes
c'était à refaire on ferait la même
chose et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de inhabituel abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu